et on va plus loin avec AMDA Mostafa
vide directrice adjoint de la rédaction
de L'Express bonjour à Madame égotier
binsky chroniqueur international ici
même à France 24 bonjour Gauthier
bonsoir les manifestations se
poursuivent en Iran le bras de fer avec
l'Occident aussi le site de la
télévision officielle iranienne a
diffusé une vidéo présentée comme les
aveux de deux Français Cécile colère et
Jacques Paris arrêtaient en mai dernier
par les autorités iraniennes et accusées
d'espionnage la France en des termes
assez inhabituelle il faut bien dire
pour la diplomatie des noms je cite à
une mise en scène indigne révoltant
inacceptable et contraire au droit
international cette mascarade révèle je
cite le mépris de la dignité humaine qui
caractérise les autorités iraniennes
ajoute le Quai d'Orsay qui réclame la
libération immédiate de ces deux
ressortissants à Madame mustaphavi après
Benjamin Brière emprisonné depuis deux
ans maintenant pour le même motif
d'espionnage après la chercheuse fariba
adelra emprisonné elle aussi pour
atteinte à la sécurité nationale que
cherche les autorités iraniennes d'après
malheureusement c'était un nouvel
illustration de ce qu'on peut appeler la
stratégie des otages de Téhéran qui
consiste à régulièrement emprisonné soit
des ressortissants de pays européens
avec lequel il est en discussion en
négociation soit parfois des binationaux
généralement ça s'est fait beaucoup
comme fariba adelca toujours dans ce
même voilà on sait que on se souvient de
la prise d'otages de l'ambassade
américaine en 79 c'est dans l'ADN du
régime islamique de d'utiliser en fait
des
victimes entre guillemets
qui peuvent lui servir de monnaie
d'échange de sources de moyens de
pression sur les états pendant le but
d'obtenir que ce soit parfois d'avoir
des des gels de fonds qui peuvent être
gelés à l'étranger ça peut être
comme par hasard des questions
politiques ça peut être dans le dossier
du nucléaire iranien que c'est ces
otages malheureusement servent de moyens
de pression alors qu'on voyait ces
derniers jours la France revenir sur une
inodure Gauthier un peu à l'image de ce
qu'on avait observé sous le rang Fabius
oui c'est exact c'est parce que
effectivement à l'époque où il était au
mystère étrangères accident du nucléaire
et aussi
inflexible oui parce que si vous voulez
le l'attitude de la République islamique
d'Iran dans les négociations pour le
nucléaire on voit très bien que jusqu'à
présent c'était une sorte d'assurance
vie cette affaire du nucléaire c'est à
dire que sans le pousser trop loin il
fallait de temps en temps je parle pour
Téhéran il fallait de temps en temps
avancer un certain nombre de choses
effrayantes on va les caractériser comme
ça et puis de temps en temps reculer
parce que cela avait aussi une vertu
interne qui était de faire accroître
pour ceux qui voulaient bien le croire
que cet Occident en décrié que
l'environnement février était désireux
d'anéantir la République islamique et
que donc il fallait parler fort et de
dans la même veine si j'ose dire on
avait la possibilité précisément dans
des affaires personnelles de
d'espionnage d'avoir ce discours là
aussi or là que se passe-t-il c'est vrai
que la France répond d'une manière assez
verte qui
dépasse les canons de la diplomatie
entre parenthèses moi j'ai envie de vous
dire si c'est pour justement affaiblir
la République le régime d'embola tant
mieux hein faut pas bouder notre plaisir
là-dessus mais les canons de la
diplomatie sont effectivement dépassés
mais parce que il y a cette récurrence
du problème du nucléaire iranien avec
les drones Iraniens qui font un sacré
carnage en ce moment dans les rangs
Ukrainiens ou Téhéran dit mais non on y
est pour rien à chaque fois Téhéran se
tient en dehors comme le président
raciste qui mais non c'est l'extérieur
qui est responsable de la contestation
donc vous voyez qu'il y a des il y a des
choses qui bougent qui sont en lien avec
une relative très relative fragilité
du régime iranien en ce moment et puis
de l'autre côté les conséquences de
l'action iranienne en Ukraine et le fait
aussi que tout ça baigne dans ses
tentatives plus ou moins avortées de
reprendre langue avec tes rangs pour la
question du nucléaire tout ça fait un
environnement qui fait bouger à la fois
les procédés des uns mais aussi des
autres d'où ce langage probablement de
la diplomatie française il est certain
que là la question du nucléaire n'avance
pas vraiment et c'est vrai que ce serait
un bon moment pour Téhéran d'avoir une
avancée sur le sujet donc c'est
difficile évidemment c'est jamais c'est
la diplomatie c'est jamais une science
exacte l'action an n'entraîne pas
l'action B mais voilà le régime joue un
peu un billard à trois bandes
de faire bouger le dossier nucléaire il
faut dire que ça intervient sur fond de
répression une répression d’ailleurs
bien documenté avec ces informations qui
remontent comme celle du Bel outils avec
ses 82 morts de la répression à zaedan
d'après Amnesty International oui et
c'est compliqué derrière permettra de de
se réhabiliter aux yeux des Occidentaux
oui oui mais c'est très intéressant dans
la contestation qu'il y a en ce moment
en Iran donc quand même depuis presque
trois semaines suite à la mort de ma
famille on voit que là cette composante
ethnique qui est très intéressante très
importante puisque les balouches comme
les Kurdes comme d'autres populations
iraniennes sont ce sont déjà rebeller
contre le régime et son déjà dans cette
démarche un peu de contestation donc un
moment on se demande dans quel sens ça
peut aller l'idée d'avoir les minorités
qui se mobilisent beaucoup plus fort et
donc ils sont aussi réprimés de manière
assez forte mais voilà il a répression à
un moment donné ça quand on voit ses
étudiantes quand on voit les menaces de
grève générale on peut se dire que s'il
y a les minorités la jeunesse voilà il
se passe il se passe quand même quelque
chose différente de ce qu'on avait
observé jusqu'à présent avec un risque
peut-être de balkanisation aussi du pays
qui est une grillade aussi de de de
communauté religieuse oui parce que la
tentation pour tes rangs peut être
effectivement de mettre cela sur le
compte de minorité ethnique qui seraient
précisément en but par principe par
principe ethno ethnique contre contre
Téhéran donc ça on l'aura probablement
cette cette assertion là mais en ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est
qu'effectivement par rapport à 2009 par
rapport à 2017 etc il y a quelque chose
de plus radical dans cette contestation
alors sans doute parce que les échecs du
passé aussi servent de leçon
c'est-à-dire que quand on a protesté
contre la réelle élection de harmonie
nedjad il a suffi entre guillemets
d'emprise je dis ça avec beaucoup de vie
mais n'emprisonner Moussavi pour que la
révolte cesse quasi immédiatement alors
que là on se dit qu'il y a des leçons
justement intégrées du passé et qu'en
plus de cela quand vous voyez par
exemple les les qualificatifs qui sont
donnés au Guide suprême par la rue c'est
quand même une remise en cause radicale
de ce qui fait le fondement de cette
république et là il me semble que à
travers le sort des femmes et ce qu'elle
revendique qui est une liberté mais
élémentaire
qu'il y a justement une critique
essentiellement cette fois qui devient
politique alors qu'auparavant elle était
certes politique mais aussi limité à des
besoins immédiats qui ne sont pas
méprisables loin de là mais qui était
beaucoup plus j'allais dire pragmatique
là on vise me semble-t-il un étage
au-dessus et ce que est exact il va
falloir voir par exemple si les grèves
générales qui sont annoncées par les
ouvriers font boule de neige et se
joignent à ce mouvement un pan du récit
du narratif nécessaire à cette
théocratie pour fonctionner est en train
de tomber la Mostafa V c'est sûr que là
on est plus seulement dans de la révolte
économique ou de la révolte politique
contra scrutin on est dans quelque chose
on est le voile le voile c'est on dit
que c'est la ligne rouge pour ce régime
mais c'est vrai qu'au début de la
révolution qui n'était pas qu'islamique
qu'il faut le rappeler la révolution de
79 elle était c'était une composante
plus large de la société c'était des
gens communistes des gens un peu voilà
des étudiants révolutionnaire etc le
moment où ça a basculé ou vraiment le
régime la côté islamique l'a emporter
c'est à partir du moment où le voile a
été imposé c'est pour ça que c'est
vraiment le pilier c'est le cœur du
régime mais à partir de là si ça
s'effondre tout est possible une
répression qui suscite un élan de
solidarité assez assez inédit un Gautier
comme ces femmes qui en France ou au
Parlement européen on l'a vu avec une
députée suédoise d'origine iranienne ce
couple voilà on la voit l'image se coupe
une mèche de cheveux c'est dire si là
aussi
ce mouvement il est différent aussi dans
la répercussion dans la résonance qu'il
a à l'étranger oui peut-être restons
prudent parce que comme par exemple vous
voyez ce qui s'est passé en France avec
donc essentiellement des actrices qui
sont coupées une messe de cheveux
derrière vous avez un collectif et puis
vous avez la comédie Isabelle Carré qui
a dit oui mais il s'agit pas de
protester contre le voile chacun a le
droit de le porter et derrière en même
temps que vous aviez la musique de Bella
Ciao qui est une musique italienne
d'inspiration anarchiste et qui a servi
à la révolte des résistants contre les
nazis vous voyez qu'il y a comme
toujours en France je voudrais je ne
voudrais pas mais faites attention bon
alors moi je trouve ça très bien les
bonnes actions vous vous trouvez que le
message est devient trop complexe à
force de vouloir aménager susceptible il
est ambigu complexe on pourrait le
clarifier mais il est ambiguë donc
attention je pense que par exemple ce
qu'a fait cette députée suédoise
d'origine iranienne et beaucoup plus
importante beaucoup plus marquant que
des velléités certes sympathiques mais
un peu on va dire complaisante vis-à-vis
de la marketisation d'une lutte qui est
évidemment capitale mais j'aimerais être
sûr que toutes ces personnalités
françaises et fait quelque chose de
politiquement fort je n'en suis pas ça
il y a de la complaisance ça manque de
cohérence à dire finalement oui à tomber
le voile signe peut-être
d'asservissement en Iran mais oui à la
liberté du port du voile ici en France y
compris par ceux qui le revendiquent
dans les écoles notamment oui donc moi
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec toutes ces
cons je pense comme tout comme tous mes
confrères qui d'origine iranienne je
sais que on a tous un peu de difficultés
avec cette comparaison sans cesse entre
la France pays des libertés quand même
où chacun fait quand même plus ou moins
ce qu'il veut et l'Iran ou les femmes
notamment vu depuis 43 ans sous le jour
d'une république qui les empêche non
seulement de de
d'apparaître comme elles veulent mais
aussi donc d'hériter de voilà tout un
c'est tout un tas le problème c'est
qu'en France le voile cristallise
plusieurs questions voilà des questions
politiques des questions sociétales en
Iran on parle vraiment de le voile et le
symbole de toute une répression qui est
bien plus large que juste la question de
ce qu'on met ou pas sur ses cheveux et
face à Lyon et la Russie un se dresse
désormais un bloc ici en Europe non plus
de 27 États non ils sont 44 les états
qu'on vit au lancement de la communauté
politique européenne une idée sortie au
départ de l'esprit d'Emmanuel Macron et
qui trouve donc sa concrétisation
officielle aujourd'hui à Prague pour
cette grande cérémonie de lancement elle
se met de plus ça me down un sommet de
plus mais une belle réussite
diplomatique pour le président Macron il
faut quand même le reconnaître puisque
il a il a lancé ça un peu un moment
donné où on pensait que
l'Europe pouvait être fragilisée face à
la face à l'attaque contre l'Ukraine
mais on a quand même cette photo
symbolique là aujourd'hui on était quand
même dans le symbole on était où est-ce
qui était placé Erdogan loin du
président grec et du représentant
chypriote on avait listrot toute seule
un peu dans un coin on avait Macron au
milieu à côté du président du Premier
ministre tchèque voilà il y avait
c'était une histoire de symbole on a ce
magnifique château de Prague l'idée
c'était d'apparaître uni évidemment
c'était tout ce qui comptait finalement
c'était Prague Prague évidemment c'est
une ville qui dans l'histoire face à
l'URSS face à la pression russe et
extrêmement symbolique donc voilà
c'était pas je suis pas sûr de du sommet
à plus ou moins long terme mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'était assez fort
avec Zelinski qui sont venu qui a appelé
évidemment à punir la Russie on a on
avait quelque chose de symboliquement
très fort une idée maligne Gauthier
d'arrimé le royaume-unioro la Turquie au
bloc occidental ou bien un moyen surtout
de se donner bonne conscience vis-à-vis
de secret je suis d'accord avec un homme
c'est pas forcément inutile ne serait-ce
qu'à cause des résultats des dernières
élections en Europe si vous prenez la
Suède si vous prenez l'Italie qui
éventuellement au prix de sa bonne
volonté très marquée à droite pour
récupérer des livraisons de carburant
par la Russie ça n'est pas inutile de
faire ce genre de choses tout du moins
de le montrer au moins même si on sait
qu'il y a des fractures derrière on sait
aussi que cette fédération de l'Europe
cette se rassemblement de l'Europe
jusqu'à présent même s'il y a des
failles ne fonctionnent pas trop mal bon
que le que le Royaume-Uni soit présent
est important aussi dans la mesure où
l'effort de guerre ukrainien est
fortement soutenu aussi par le royaume
des pays comme la comme l'Ukraine dans
l'antichambre de l'Union européenne
parce que c'est ça aussi que symbolise
cette
union politique alors là c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué surtout que de fait il y
a presque concurrence entre la Turquie
et l'Ukraine mais en même temps on peut
se dire aussi que la Turquie avec ses
chemins de traverse par rapport à
l'Union européenne n'est pas au plus au
plus clair vis-à-vis de cela a-t-elle
vraiment envie de d'y adhérer ou bien
est-ce que un rôle justement
satellitaire qui lui permettrait d'être
un pied à l'ouest et un pied à l'Est
comme elle essaye de le faire quasiment
permanence est-ce que c'est pas ça qui
lui conviendrait alors que l'Ukraine là
on a bien vu que notamment après la
demande de Zelinski demande d'adhérer à
l'OTAN qui qui qui est une réponse au
fond à la mise le fait accompli de
l'annexion des régions du dan bass ça
c'est quelque chose qui est important
aussi même en affichage même si on sait
que ça ne peut pas se faire justement
l'Ukraine candidate autant candidate à
l'Union européenne devait pieux et on
s'est bien pourquoi aujourd'hui à Madame
c'est que l'entrée dans l'Ain dans
l'autre plongerait automatiquement les
pays européens dans une guerre avec la
Russie oui non mais on sait on sait que
que ce soit que l'Ukraine en particulier
à peu de chance d'avoir son adhésion
finalisée on sait aussi que finalement
je suis pas certaine que l'Europe est en
vie de grandir que l'Union européenne en
tout cas et envie de grandir à ce stade
c'est déjà assez compliqué à 27 donc si
on devait intégrer des pays comme
l'Ukraine ou la Serbie qui ont d'autres
problématiques ce serait même sans la
guerre entre guillemets assez compliquée
donc c'est vrai que c'est une manière un
peu maligne mais d'ailleurs ça inquiète
un des pays justement comme la Serbie de
se dire voilà vous allez nous mettre de
côté nous nous allez là c'est plus
compliqué pour la Turquie parce que la
Turquie en effet comme zégotiers ne sait
pas si vraiment si elle veut adhérer
mais il est certain que
l'Ukraine de n'adhérera pas demain à
l'Union européenne
ni à l'otanemment ce qui laisse
effectivement aujourd'hui ces pays
directement exposés 44 pays il va se
passer quoi maintenant Gauthier mais ça
c'est quoi la prochaine étape
concrètement de cette union politique
pour éviter que comme l'Union pour la
Méditerranée par exemple elle ne sombre
sitôt le premier sommet accompli
je sais pas forcément répondre à cette
question parce que c'est vrai ce qu'on a
dit était l'important c'était de marquer
cette association peut-être de marquer
aussi les esprits de ceux qui la
composent en leur disant vous voyez
quand on se met ensemble ça a quand même
un effet par rapport à l'OTAN on a vu
que la réponse de stolenberg était la
réponse habituelle sauf qu'il a dit il
faut que ça se fasse avec l'adhésion des
autres pays il n'a pas rappelé
effectivement tout ce qui fait que cette
adhésion est empêchée c'est-à-dire
notamment le fait qu'un pays qui veut
adhérer à l'OTAN doit avoir son
territoire une forme de concorde une
forme de paix etc doit être en paix
sinon il précipite via l'article 5 ou
les pays de la guerre explique que la
Suède puisse ou le ou le ou la Finlande
puisse adhérer automatique enfin en tout
cas sans poser des difficultés tandis
que l'Ukraine elle en est en travée tout
à fait alors dans ce contexte là est-ce
que c'est pas peut-être finalement un
lot de consolation aussi de dire vous
êtes là on vous oublie pas
je voudrais que il y a un an ce type de
grémium de réunion nous aurait peut-être
fait rire enfin ont été terrible il est
un peu moins aujourd'hui non seulement à
cause des événements mais parce que dans
ce domaine là la puissance du symbole
est capitale et que tout le monde en use
y compris même bien sûr la Russie lui a
fait contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
en s'en servant une fois de plus de
tribune contre la Russie pour dire
attention les chats russes arrivent à
Prague une fois de plus oui évidemment
qui n'est pas avare de symboles lui-même
depuis le début dans sa communication
depuis le début de la guerre à profiter
de cette tribune et il a il a fait entre
guillemets dans ce qui est vrai que ce
qui au-delà du symbole on est aussi
voilà il y a une image de multi
latéralisme à une époque où le petit
réalisme paraît un peu obsolète face au
bloc russe face au bloc chinois face au
bloc américain l'idée de voilà l'Europe
réaffirme sa capacité à dialoguer à être
dans le multi latéralisme à y compris
intégré des gens comme Erdogan ou le
dialogue n'est pas toujours simple merci
merci Madame mustaphavi merci également
à vous Gauthier c'est la fin on va plus
loin on se retrouve dans trois minutes
pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]